elon musk 6.7 billion dollars in
compensation last year
uh let me
say that one more time elon musk is comp
last year was 6.7 billion dollars that's
11 times more than the second
highest-paid ceo this is a business
insider story tesla's self-styled tekken
inc
received six point six six billion
dollars in compensation 2020 nearly 12
times out of donald pay index musk
hasn't received his billions in cash his
compensation was come comprised of
option awards giving him the right to
acquire tesla shares at a set price 2020
second highest paid executive was mike
uh piak kos
ceo of oak street health who received
568 million dollars the top 10 features
executives from seven different
companies and it's entirely comprised of
men
versus good rx good prescription holding
cosio trevor and douglas they were at
497 million dollars a bunch of different
names you see on the list that you're
not going to know many of these names by
the way but musk 6.66 billion too much
money too little money or about the
right number my first reaction is holy
crap that seems really low to me i mean
we are talking about a guy who started
the company who runs the company who is
the face of the company he didn't start
tesla though
like i said before you interrupted me
we're talking about guy that runs the
company that is the face of the company
and that basically saved the company hey
look it's all tied to performance all
right they had a great year i don't see
how this is out of line at all he took
zero in cash and people want to lump him
in with the ceo overpay narrative
i think it's actually the opposite i
mean i think he should be commended for
it he made thousands of people rich last
year the stock price went from 90
at the beginning of the year to 700 he
lives in a glorified shack right a 50
000 little thing prefab thing that he
lives in it's not like he's flaunting
his wealth
you know he used to take a salary his
salary was 23 000 in 2019 56 000 in
2018. so
i think he should be applauded i think
this is a great story where someone is
tied to revenues of the company and 6.6
b sounds about right i'm so sick of
counting other people's money man like i
really am like why what does it matter
to you like people somehow they view
this as like it's one one pie like like
our economy is just one big old pizza
pie and this dude's taking giant slices
so none of us have any more
his the food he eats doesn't make you
[ __ ] man like who cares like it's a
great story good for him i'm a tesla
shareholder it's been awesome for me man
i love the guy but i don't care i don't
care how much athletes make i don't care
about owners make i don't care how much
anybody else makes it doesn't bother me
it doesn't interest me dude what are you
making you want that money go make
something what are you making man like i
don't care like these people are like
how dare this guy make this much money i
always go back to that old quote and
this is not a new thing this was there
was some activist commie freaking
journalist a hundred years ago asking
babe ruth don't you think it's
outrageous that you make you make more
money than the president united states
and bay ruth without even skipping a
because i had a better year
you know what i mean like yeah
yeah i had a better you made more money
than herbert humphrey i had a better
year yeah yeah dude like come on man who
cares like like is he taking away from
people is he taking away like what is he
doing he's creating jobs he's he's
creating what you can't make these
people happy there's nothing you can do
to make these people make that kind of
money hey what's
is he is he doing it through oil is he
doing it through fossil fuels he's
saving the universe he's saving the
environment he's gonna he's gonna
colonize mars who cares now the one
thing i do get pissy okay here you go
you want me to get pissy at elon musk
what the hell does he need seven billion
dollars of taxpayer money for with nasa
what's he need that for that i'll get
pissy with i'll get pissy with him and
bezos going back and forth with nasa
over oh no i deserve the six billion
dollars no i deserve how would you guys
pay for it well that's not the most a
separate company though right that isn't
doing as well as tesla sure spacex fine
whatever co you know you could call it
whatever you want to call it but
look
they don't need our money that you want
me to get pissy i'll get pissy about
that all right but he makes his own
money in the private sector god bless
bro who cares
that's your position as well you're fine
with that with him making that kind of
money i have no problem with that well
listen kudos to elon musk he had a
killer year
and uh guy's now worth what a couple
hundred billion is he had a couple
hundred years no no he's he's a one
fifty buck fifty what is the matter with
him like what's he wearing how does he
pronounce his son's name or daughter's
name i know that is gina what was this
oh it's crazy
is it really kidding i think he said it
was pronounced sasha sasha and is he
going to leave anybody even though it's
like
yeah yeah it's like sasha what is what
is elan's long-term aspiration do you
think his long term wants to live
forever it is
do you think that's what it is
people on mars i think that's that's
i think they're all i'm telling you i
think the the elites the global elites
right i think the new thing is longevity
they want to live to 200 300 400 years
old
i think they already um automatically
assume that they're gonna get close to
that but i think his
i think what drives him is to get tesla
fix so he can get out of there somehow
find a way to exit and just concentrate
on putting people on mars digital do you
think we're gonna get to a point where
people could live 200 300 years no no no
i don't think we'll see it i mean could
it eventually happen what would you
define life as
yeah right what would you define like
dead
seriously what do you think we're going
to get to people yeah like what like 300
years well you'd have you'd have to
define life like if they could upload
your consciousness into some
you know uh if they could somehow you
know
data map your consciousness and upload
it into you know some sort of matrix and
you can theoretically i know guys
about that live forever i mean is that
life i mean i we'd have to redefine what
life is
said in an interview that that's what he
wants is eventually technically you
could put your consciousness in like a
computer and live forever i i i did a cs
lewis you had me reading c.s lewis the
other day and i saw an unbelievable cs
lewis quote and i said you you are you
do not have a soul you are a soul you
have a body this is just a space suit
this is a space suit man like all we are
is with this is a this is a containment
for the bio for you you know so
yeah like if they if they could isolate
the soul what's this what's the say i
mean if you're religious you think you
live forever anyway right on a different
you know
spiritual plane but you know what i
think longevity is the goal i really do
i think that that everything that
they're doing uh is for them to be able
to to
sustain their lifestyle forever and i
will answer this i i do believe that we
could see people living to be 150 and
above and just look at
just look at what we're already
witnessing look at tom brady who looks
like he's 30 who's playing like he's 32
there's no indication that he's done in
one or two or three years and he's 44
years old right now and before that i
mean think about george blanda right he
was the first nfl player to play at the
age of 40. he looked like he was 63. you
know and he felt like he was 80 yeah
brady so if we're seeing this type of
advancement yeah and it's but we're not
yeah we're not we're not working in the
mines at 12 years old and smoking
heaters our whole life anymore either
man there is someone alive today that
will live to be a thousand years old
okay
it's extraordinary to me
that it's such an inc what is it
incendiary incendiary claim a thousand
years old
kai what what is this
spoof of a site what's what
who is that independent someone doing it
uh independent
got it looks like a viagra commercial
all right there you go thousand years
i don't know if that's gonna be by the
way if you're watching this if you're
watching this right now thumbs up
do you think
in our lifetime we're gonna see people
being able to live to 300 years old if
you're watching this yes no maybe
comment below do you think we're going
to see people getting to a number like
obviously it's not going to happen in
our lifetime because that means we need
200 more years for that to be taking
place but we're going to get to a point
where people are going to live towards
200 would you want to live 300 years i
think 300 is pushing it to be honest
with you i wouldn't mind like is this
funny is it still like until death do us
part that we got to do 270 years
together
that's when marriage becomes about term
limits
270 years
breaking a new generation
would you want to live 200 years
20 years
yeah i'd want to live forever honestly
how many years do i get to like actually
like
you know be functioning moving you know
what i mean like assume all of it would
you
want to live forever ah yeah i kind of
like i kind of like living gerard you
can only bench press 350 at the age of
140 would you do it yeah
how cool that what do you think yes no
maybe
i don't know i don't think uh i don't
think i'd want to live forever
for sure but maybe
that's where i'd said that would you
want to live forever though but why not
why like what are you busy doing
something else i can't i can't i can't
conceive of not living i can't conceive
i can't conceive of of being anything
other than this consciousness living
forever now i'm good like the movie uh
uh what is that age of adeline lightning
strikes you and your own age yeah you
know and you just you well the green
mile i would tell you i would tell you
this i would never want to live forever
if the people i love couldn't live
forever as well that's what exactly what
i'm thinking yeah i wouldn't watch
yeah if it's like everybody i don't know
i don't know about that i don't know
about that why do you think they're so
concerned about population control pat
there's not gonna be enough room for
them
they're gonna live for a thousand years
the plebeians gotta get out of the way
but i can see the the the powerful
people who have all the money in the
world sitting behind closed doors trying
to find a solution on how they can have
the ability to do it i mean look at kobe
bryant when he wanted to extend his
career he'd go to germany and have his
blood spill you know you can find all
these technological advances you can do
and by the way do you think elon musk
loses credibility when he talks about
going to mars it seems so preposterous
so impossible and yet he continues to
drive at the fact that he thinks it
could happen wait wait how was it
preposterous it's it's a matter of time
to get there two years it's a matter of
time you know you gotta also think we've
taken you tomorrow ten years ago to have
rockets that go up in the air and come
down and are fine was also insane yeah
yeah yeah so everything he said he's
going to do is kind of
true that but what about the actual like
temperature on mine in fairness and
gravity in fairness elon musk said i
believe it was elon musk who said on
this very channel that giannis on
tacompulco would never win
an nba final
you know what you need to you need to
pay closer attention to what i say not
out of 18 of the available game okay so
man i was actually
dominant i didn't i didn't realize it
was it was it was an apple contract so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye
[Music]